[Musique]
bienvenue dans le débrief du doc
aujourd'hui nous allons parler d'un film
diffusé en exclusivité sur rt france de
l'or dans la boue il se déroule aux
philippines dans la mine d'or la plus
célèbre du monde mais elle ne doit sa
réputation qu aux effroyables conditions
de travail des mineurs des adultes mais
aussi des enfants qui sont immergés dans
des couloirs de bouées pour en parler je
m'entretiens aujourd'hui avec maelys
charlas bonjour merci d'être avec nous
alors vous êtes directrice de la chambre
de commerce et d'industrie des
philippines et vous avez personnellement
rédigé une note sur les mines d'or donc
les scènes de ce documentaire de laure
dans la boue vous sont familières alors
qu'est ce qu'on y voit et bien tout cela
se déroule à part à calais à 300 km de
manille et à des adultes mais aussi des
enfants doivent s'engouffrer dans des
galeries très précaire à des couloirs
debout et ce pour quoi
et bien pour quelques fragments d'or
finalement quelques euros alors est-ce
que les scènes de ce documentaire sont
conformes à ce que vous avez observé sur
le terrain mais ils disent charles a
alors je dirais que yann ya très peu
d'infrastructures qui sont qui tiennent
le coup aux philippines c'est vrai et
que en effet c'est une réalité qui
existe
cela dit je dirais pas que c'est
l'essentiel en des mines d'or et je
dirais surtout que le gouvernement a
depuis quelques années pris conscience
du danger qu'ils représentent pour la
population et pour les enfants en effet
les femmes qui sont dans ces secteurs
minier et depuis quelques années tous à
la transformation des infrastructures et
à essayer de trouver de nouvelles
technologies pour éviter ces sites
illégaux
oui alors justement il y as peut-être
des centaines de mines d'or en tout cas
dans ce pays
est-ce que elles sont légales ou
illégales elle a en fait aux philippines
étant donné qu'ils sont dans le souci
d'améliorer les choses ils ont augmenté
les standards de sécurité pouvant
permettre à une mine d'or d'être dite
légale de ce fait
l heure actuelle il n'y a que 17 min qui
arrivent à obtenir ce statut légal dans
le sens où elles elles tiennent tous les
tous les standards de sécurité
nécessaires donc oui il ya des centaines
de mines et aux philippines beaucoup
sont des micros mine c'est des petits
gisements qui sont exploités et donc la
plupart sont dit illégal en fait avec
voilà ce chiffre d'une vingtaine qui
sont vraiment certifié par le
gouvernement alors dans ce documentaire
on s'aperçoit que les mineurs
travaillent dans des conditions
effrayantes insoutenable je vous propose
de le découvrir dans ce premier extrait
il est attaché nous ne pouvons pas le
perdre
on utilise également des bouchons pour
empêcher l'eau et la boue de pénétrer
dans nos oreilles
et nous mettons des masques qui couvre
la moitié du visage et le nez
je m'appelle la polo garden j'ai élevé
mes enfants avec l'argent que j'ai gagné
ici
c'est la seule source de revenus pour
mes amis et moi parfois quand vous êtes
au fond
vous sentez que c'est trop dangereux et
qu'il vaut mieux remonter l'arrivée
d'air il peut expliquer ce qu'il fait à
quoi ça sert kobe bryant
[Musique]
il a des problèmes pour obtenir de
l'aide parfois c'est effrayant
et si les parois s'effondrer vous seriez
ensevelies s'il est impossible de vous
remonter ils coupent leur ont tout
simplement la corde et voulait seront
sous l'eau c'est déjà arrivé à mon oncle
alors on apprend dans ce documentaire
donc les accidents dans ces mines
illégales les accidents mortels sont
fréquents il ya également de multiples
maladies est ce que vous confirmez
oui tout à fait la pollution déjà la
pollution des sols à base de mercure est
très très dangereuse
il ya d'autres produits métalliques qui
sont toxiques qui qui qui porte à la
dangerosité de la santé des travailleurs
ou si vous voyez bien les conditions
sont assez précaire c'est avec des bouts
de plastique et terra mais surtout ce
qui est très dangereux là c'est
l'effondrement des sols ce qu'on appelle
le laine sliding aux philippines et qui
sont très courants sur tout les
philippines sont sur des plaques
tectoniques et que du coup on a quand
même des séismes quand même assez récent
sur lle de l'usn cnil en plus volcanique
donc oui oui niveau santé maladies de
poche présume aussi énormément de ce
qu'on voit aussi dans le documentaire
et puis et surtout le danger d'avoir ces
sols qui ne tiennent pas et les
travailleurs qui finissent au fond et
tout prix alors justement c'est
certainement en voie d'amélioration
puisque en 2016 et 2017 le président
philippin rodrigo duterte sous
l'impulsion de son ancien ministre de
l'environnement regin à lopez qui est
malheureusement décédé depuis a fermé un
grand nombre de mines dont vous nous
vous nous direz comment ça s'est produit
qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors il ya eu
plusieurs scandales déjà avec des mines
qui m'ont causé la mort de plus à une
petite centaine souvient dans un
incident particulier où il y avait une
centaine de mineurs qui étaient étaient
morts dans un accident ça ça a créé
dudus coke
aussi le président du trt et un
président qui prend des mesures
drastiques
quand il ya des problèmes et cela tient
aussi sur les causes environnementales
et des causes des salariés puisque c'est
un gouvernement qui met en valeur aussi
beaucoup les travailleurs de toute façon
ça fait partie de son mandat
donc étant donné que ses drastiques
s'est tout de suite la fermeture des
sites ce qui cause bien sûr des
problèmes aussi au niveau des
travailleurs qui se retrouvent sans rien
parce que ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
là c'est pas les philippines qui
destination très belle touristique
lassé des sites où il ya aucun ocariz
art donc il ya très peu de travail en
fait et c'est pour ça aussi que c'est
travailleurs prennent les risques qu'il
le faut car ils n'ont pas tellement
d'alternative au niveau emploi dans ces
entités
loin de tout en tout cas c'est la
ministre de l'environnement qui a poussé
le président à fermer ses mines en tout
cas à l'époque en 2016 et 2017 quelles
sont les atteintes sur l'environnement
de ces mines alors ces mines déjà
polluent les sols elle empoisonne les
seuls ça c'est je pense la chose qu'il a
plus en plus importante
au-delà de ça au niveau des espèces
animales qui sont locales elles sont
très endommagées étant donné que ça
pollue les sols barrel la nutrition
qu'il en vient au tour est contaminée il
ya plein de types de maladies aux
philippines il ya elle s'est surtout
dans les provinces en général il faut
pas forcément malades dans les grandes
villes etc mais quand on est dans les
provinces un peu reculé on peut avoir
des amibes est tout autre de parasites
en fait qui viennent aux i do sal
certaines mines ont rouvert depuis
est-ce que c'était dû à la pression des
exploitants locaux aussi des pays
importateurs ou éventuellement des
investisseurs étrangers comment ça s'est
passé leur ouverture et la réouverture
je pense qu'elle est aussi dans un cadre
où
où on essaye de voir un essai une
relance économique je pense qu'il ya un
peu de ça déjà
oui évidemment le lobbying du secteur
privé c'est toujours très important et
ça en fait partie pack étrangers un
localement la plupart des mines sont
détenus par des corporations questions
locales et donc là que dans ce contexte
là il ya une pression mais je pense
qu'il ya surtout aussi une pression de
tous et toutes ces personnes dont la vie
dépend des mines et qui se retrouvent
sans travail et donc pas pouvoir acheter
du riz qui est très important ici qu'une
alimentation première des yeux etc
en plus c'est pas un bord de mer en
cette ville particulièrement ce qui fait
ce qui fait qu'ils peuvent pas être
autosuffisant comme comme les philippins
peuvent l'être dans beaucoup d'endroits
qui sont pour nous par asie paradisiaque
pour eux c'est des endroits il n'y a pas
de travail mais ils dépendent
complètement de la mer et de et de leurs
productions locales de l'écumé
d'alimentation lassé des endroits assez
difficile d'avoir sa propre agriculture
pour survivre donc tout cela tout ce
contexte en fait fait que c'est bien
beau de fermer les mines
mais s'il ya par un accompagnement
derrière suffisant les personnes se
retrouvent sans rien du tout du coup
c'est pour ça qu'on est toujours dans
une acceptation un peu de conditions
plus difficiles pour survivre tout
simplement on parlera des mesures pour
un meilleur accompagnement des
travailleurs mais en tout cas les mines
illégales elles ce qu'elles sont
contrôlés aujourd'hui est-ce que s'il y
en a de nouvelles qui se crée des
personnes et forces de l'ordre qui
patrouillent pour empêcher d'en créer de
nouvelles
en fait cette question est là une
réponse qui sera un peu paradoxal je
m'en excuse aux philippines c'est un
pays qui est quand même assez militarisé
avec une présence de la police ce qui
nous parfois étranges et nous choque
pourtant on ne se sent pas forcément en
insécurité ici mais on voit très
facilement des militaires et puis dans
les zones comme ça un peu plus reculer
c'est vraiment la police que bach en
gagnant la bourgogne ccc ccc comme un
petit village dirait
et donc on estime que oui il ya une
présence militaire mais encore une fois
bon les policiers c'est des cousins les
frères de personnes et il faut savoir
que dans ces sites si les gens en
dépendent pour vivre pour vivre
la police peut avoir une espèce
d'inertie à dire qu'elle est présente
c'est un sentiment qu'on a un feeling on
voit beaucoup de police beaucoup de
militaires très souvent donc on
s'habitue pourtant ça ne veut pas dire
que va y avoir des actions très très
fortes qui sont prises je dirais pas
qu'il ferme les yeux mais mais c'est
vrai que je pense qu il ya une espèce
d'empathie aussi qui dans le collectif
aux philippines on est très dans le
collectif on veut pas face à la misère
probablement les policiers des
militaires faire un oeil en laissant
passer puisque il ya c'est un peu que
douala tout le monde le groupe a bondi à
rien très bien leur écoute on va marquer
une courte pause on se retrouve juste
après avec maylis chars là pour parler
du documentaire de laure dans la boue
de retour dans le débrief du dock pour
parler du documentaire de laure dans la
boue qui se déroule aux philippines avec
maelys charlas qui est directrice
générale de la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie aux philippines alors les
mines ont rouvert pour certaines en tout
cas est ce que les conditions de travail
des mineurs ont été améliorés comment ça
se passait très ouverture progressive
des mines
il ya un souci de formation de
sollicitation directe les premiers pas
vers l'amélioration sont vraiment en
cours depuis comme on like quelques
années aussi un contexte sanitaire qui
fait que de toute façon la santé est
plus que le premier sujet aux
philippines et donc ça s'accompagne par
des mesures de formation et mais qui
sont limitées parce que de toute façon
il y aller les impossibilités du manque
d'infrastructures qui restent il reste
quand même très important
alors comment la france avait réagi à la
fermeture de ces mines est ce qu'on a
des concessions des marchés avec ses
mines ces ressources là on a des
sociétés qui france s qui sont
implantées ici aux philippines et qui ne
sont pas en contact direct avec les
exploitations minières mais qui en
revanche entretiennent des relations
indirectes à savoir fournir du carburant
fournir éventuellement des machines et
autres donc la présence française est un
petit peu un petit peu là après comme je
disais tout à l'heure on essaie surtout
des sociétés locales de l'espace peuvent
difficilement intervenir ou avoir un mot
quand à quant aux conditions d
exploitation des mines en revanche qui
se voit dans le secteur minier mais pas
seulement dans d'autres secteurs
les grosses corporations qui sont ici
aux philippines ont tendance à avoir ce
qu'on appelle drs
des programmes rse donc c'est des
programmes ou we met en place dans
différents secteurs des programmes de
formation d'assistance quand ils le
peuvent
quand il ya des budgets aussi de
matériels et parce que là on voit bien
qu'ils ont aucun matériel en aux
travailleurs qu'on voyait un petit peu
avant donc donc voilà c'est un petit peu
l'accompagnement qui peut être fait et
qui a un qui est un petit peu fait mais
légèrement après il faut savoir que
l'infrastructure c'est au coeur du
mandat présidentiel aux philippines et
que tous ces problèmes d'infrastructures
ne touche pas que le secteur minier
ça touche à peu près tout il ya des
congestions deux des gros problèmes de
congestion sur manille dans le transport
en commun et on retrouve la présence
française bouygues travaux publics
freyssinet etc qui font partie libre 8
bâtiment international et tous ces
constructeurs là ont des projets surtout
un transport en commun puisque c'est
quand même aussi un des problèmes mais
il faut savoir que dans l'infrastructure
en général la présence princesse est
aussi aux philippines
vous parlez des grands groupes mais ce
que par exemple un petit investisseur
pourrait bas grâce aux structures aussi
à la chambre de commerce et d'industrie
arrivé avec peut-être davantage de
prérequis sont des conditions de travail
avec davantage des deux peut-être des
aides sociales d'ailleurs pour les
familles pour les enfants nous on
encourage énormément de toute façon et
ça fait partie du programme qu'on
appelle team france export qui a été
lancé par le gouvernement français
on encourage l'export de petits
investisseurs ou de petites pme
françaises qui ont ces technologies et
qui pourrait les exporter aux
philippines et nous la chambre de
commerce par exemple on fait ces
introductions là on participe aux
délégations les organise donc oui il
faut il faut absolument que nos pme
françaises qui ont éventuellement des
technologies s'intéresse aux philippines
c'est quelque chose que j'ai je vous
avais dit mais on estime que le les
philippines or l2
même plus grand gisement d'or en
revanche ça ne représente que 0,6 pour
cent du pib ce qui est rien du tout
c'est très paradoxal
le président philippin rodrigo duterte
et le commande souvent attendait que
c'est pour ça qu'il a aussi fermé les
mines c'est que ça contribue très peu
aux produits
aogo pib des philippines et comment on
peut s'expliquer cela parce que leur
sous sol regorge de de ressources pas
seulement d'or d'ailleurs d'autres
ressources très utile très importantes
alors que ce pastis à cause
d'infrastructures vous pensez
complètement
c'est le gros problème c'est les
infrastructures et là il ya entrepris un
sport pratiquement on appel cela
s'appelle le bild bild
ça veut dire qu'on se faire construire
construire avec plusieurs trillions de
pesos qui sont mis sur sur le budget
infrastructures pour la roadmap la aux
philippines est il si vous voulez les
infrastructures c'est tout philippines
les productions locales je pense à autre
chose je pense au sucre on a fait une
très belle étude de marché il ya pas
longtemps pour le sucre les oeufs sucre
on ya un gros manque à gagner parce
qu'il n'ya pas d'infrastructures pas ce
que les agriculteurs pas à les planteurs
de canne erreurs arrivent pas banal
bonne variété mouthe sont pas bonnes
donc lesquels voilà et tout est comme ça
en fait et c'est pour ça qu'il ya
toujours des manques à gagner aux
philippines de belles opportunités je le
répète mais il se manque
d'infrastructures bloc absolument
l'exploitation des richesses du pays
cela dit comme je les dis le
gouvernement a mis en place ce plan
d'action qui est bien sûr avec la
présence chinoise japonaise et coréenne
sur les constructions très présentes on
met des français comme je disais sont
très bons en design et il a aidé les
projets en cours et en ingénieurs
il donc donc il ya des belles
opportunités est vraiment le paradoxe
ils se retrouvent pas que dans les mines
il se retrouve dans beaucoup beaucoup de
domaines plutôt agro alimentaire puisque
les philippines repose essentiellement
du tourisme
mais aussi de tout ce qu'on appelle le
agribusiness donc c'est vraiment ou
l'agroalimentaire avec l'exportation de
ses richesses
de toute façon alors dans le
documentaire on apprend que l'or qui est
extrait par ces hommes ces femmes et ces
enfants va servir à réaliser des
bracelets des bijoux on imagine
peut-être pour une clientèle occidentale
alors j'ai parlé du côté français c'est
pas juste avec leur philippin c'est
comme une industrie l'extraction des
matières précieuses que soient les
pierres ou l'or reste assez opaque
est-ce qu'on travaille au niveau
français sur de l'or équitable par
exemple de leurs équitable philippins et
aux philippines
je dirais pas qu'on en est là encore que
la dila ne des clés steyn bilitis et le
grand grand utilise énormément ici est
aussi au coeur des soucis si vous voulez
dans le tourisme c'est pareil le
sustainability c'est très important
donc c'est cette notion de commerce
équitable mais aussi un commerce
responsable en environnement et dans le
coeur et dans le coeur des soucis aux
philippines je dirais que les le
gouvernement un petit peu regardé ce qui
se passait ailleurs et peut-être avec
des exemples de tourisme de masse en
thaïlande et donc de se faire il prend
des mesures drastiques pour éviter
[Musique]
les débordements afin de préserver le
pays parce que c'est quand même un pays
assez nationalistes aux philippines les
gens sont très fiers des philippines et
ils ont bien raison
un très très beau pays et est du coup je
dirais que cette notion de commerce
équitable sur voit de plus en plus et
surtout le le l'idée de faire des choses
eco friendly organique
c'est au coeur des priorités de classe
il ya une espèce de d'urgence de 2,2 de
changer de terrain pas d'accord alors un
point que qu'on n'a pas encore abordé
mais qui jalonnent tout le documentaire
c'est le travail des enfants à par akalé
apparemment de nombreux enfants sont
orphelins moins d'un par an est
d'ailleurs pas forcément juste à parts
égales et mai aux alentours les enfants
se précipitent vers la mine on voit donc
des images extrêmement poignante on a
même les larmes aux yeux en les voyant
je vous propose de regarder un second
extrait du documentaire de laure dans la
boue
mais pourquoi t'es pas à l'école
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas assez
d'argent pour acheter à manger
vous avez trouvé quelque chose
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que c'est je peux
voir seulement un palais juste s'ils
vont tout prendre comment tu t'appelles
avril hellip combien tu gagnes parfois
sans 15 pesos
je donne tout à ma grand mère mais le
matin il ne reste rien
et nous revenons travailler ici avec toy
mon père est mort et ma mère s'est
remariée apple ma soeur a été vendu ils
ont vendu ma soeur qu'est ce qui s'est
passé avec ton père comment il est mort
il a bu du poison à cause de ma mère je
ne veux plus te voir maman tu nous a
laissé tout seul tu nous a abandonnés tu
nous a jetés dehors sous la pluie
harold on se voit demain d'accord tu
devrais aller à la maison
des scènes extrêmement émouvante alors
est-ce que le travail des enfants est un
problème préoccupant aux philippines
oui oui là clairement où des enfants qui
travaillent aussi je pense dû fêter de
la deûle à des problèmes
d'infrastructures je pense que les
enfants avec beaucoup plus est secrète
et c'est pour ça que c'est faux les
enfants qui travaillent le travail des
enfants c'est une préoccupation mais je
dirais pas du tout que c'est la première
par contre il ya un très très fort
d'alphabétisation aux philippines ainsi
quand même population qualifiée qui va à
l'école on à 98% de d'alphabétisation
dans le pays
les philippins parle très bien anglais
ils ont leur dialecte aussi mais il
parle anglais du fait de la colonisation
et d'occupation des américains cia dans
le passé donc le travail des enfants oui
c'est un problème dans certains endroits
mais je dirais que ça reste quand même
minoritaire et que et que là je pense
que c'est des cas vraiment extrême mais
qui pas pour moi pas du tout là la
généralité aux philippines
les philippins sont très famille
ça vient aussi de l'oréal et a je pense
espagnol et catholique st fait très
catholique
donc on n'a pas envie d'en mais ses
enfants faire ça et on n'a pas envie
d'avoir des enfants qui travaillent à
9,10 dans de toute façon en général les
enfants sont participants de la dans les
familles les plus démunies du travail et
de la notion de d'avoir de l'argent
souvent l'aîné il ya vraiment cette
libéralisation avec avec a levé que la
famille mais quand bien même les enfants
pourraient aider les parents c'est très
rare que les parents ils réalisent abusé
lfr travail je dirais pas que c'est du
tout en tout cas c'est du plein gré des
enfants on voit dans le documentaire ce
qui ne rend pas la situation plus plus
simple pour eux est ce que tu fais de la
fermeture des mines
le gouvernement philippin a prévu des
compensations pour les mineurs même
illégaux bien sûr mais qui ont perdu
leurs seules ressources qui leur sert à
manger ils le disent bien sympa pour
s'acheter des voitures c'est vraiment
pour survivre ce qu'il ya des programmes
comme ça et pour les adultes et pour les
enfants pour qu'ils aillent à l'école
pour les soutenir alors l'école c'est
quand même très mis en valeur pour pour
les philippines l'école c'est la voix
des possibles on sent que les familles
se disent que par l'école on peut
réussir et que ja et que voilà il ya
plein de fonctions être professeur c'est
très bien vu est policier c'est très
bien vu
et pour revenir à votre question
financier aucune à lawrence données par
le gouvernement
là il n'y a pas de chômage technique aux
philippines
de toute façon donc là en ce moment on
voit un taux de chômage très très
importante puisqu'on est toujours un
confinement aux philippines assez fort
et est donc la seule pour vous donner un
ordre d'idée la avec le co vides et les
les personnes qui ont perdu leur travail
mais mamani la seule aide financière
donnée par l'état ça a été cinq mille
pesos qui correspond à 100 euros et
c'est tout en une fois donc emmené en a
pas de chômage technique est dur et la
police y aux philippines la règle c'est
noah cno paye donc on travaille pas on
n'a pas d'argent est ce que la france
passe à chang où vous semblez dire que
le le président philippin est très
volontariste en tout cas il met en place
des choses est ce que la france va
renforcer sa coopération alors à tous
les niveaux économique mais aussi dans
l'aide apportée aux philippines alors
j'aurais du mal à vraiment parler au nom
du gouvernement français
mais le problème c'est que le
gouvernement un philippin à ces mesures
drastiques parfois pour de bonnes causes
mais là sur la plateforme internationale
le gouvernement philippin n'est pas du
tout
très bien vu par nos amis européens donc
en ce moment il ya beaucoup plus de
temps
dû fêter que l'europe indique au
gouvernement philippin qui ne respectent
pas un certain nombre de conventions
internationales ce qui va à l'encontre
du gsp plus qu' un traitement favorable
de favorisation aux philippines leur
permettant d'exporter sans aucune taxe à
l'union européenne un certain nombre de
produits en fait est là en ce moment il
ya une guéguerre politique et une remise
en question du gsp plus parce que alors
est ce que en échange du gsp plus le e
gouvernement de lutter t doit respecter
un certain nombre de conventions
internationales et de droit de l'homme
et le gouvernement du trt a fait une
énorme politique que dans 80 avec ed
voilà une façon de faire drastique qui
font que tous les jugements et tous les
systèmes juridiques a été bafouée et et
n'a pas permis aux voilà l union
européenne pardon de d'être satisfait
sur ces fois là donc c'est un et ce
serait très grave un bailleur que les
philippines sortent du gsp plus parce
que ça représente une énorme aide pour
l'export des ressources philippe et vous
emploierez merci beaucoup à maylis
charlas d'avoir été avec nous pour
commenter ce documentaire de laure dans
la boue diffusé en exclusivité à sur rt
france je rappelle que vous êtes la
directrice générale de la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie des philippines
vous pourrez retrouver l'intégralité de
notre documentaire sur rt france point
tva bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]